- [Instructor] For a sample of pure water
at 25 degrees Celsius, the
concentration of hydronium ion
is equal to 1.0 times 10 to
the negative seventh molar.
Because the concentrations
are often very small,
it's much more convenient
to express the concentration
of hydronium ion in terms of pH.
And pH is defined as the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ion.
Since H+ and H3O+ are used
interchangeably in chemistry,
sometimes you'll see the
pH equation written out
as pH is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of H+ ion.
So to find the pH of pure water,
we just need to plug in the concentration
of hydronium ions into our equation.
So the pH is equal to the negative log
of 1.0 times 10 to the negative seventh
which is equal to 7.00.
So the pH of pure water
at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to seven.
Notice that there are
two significant figures
for the concentration
and there are two decimal
places for the final answer.
And that's because for a logarithm,
only the numbers to the
right of the decimal point
are significant figures.
Therefore, two significant
figures for a concentration
means two decimal places.
Let's say we have a sample of lemon juice
and the measured concentration
of hydronium ions
in solution is 3.6 times 10
to negative fourth molar.
Since we have the concentration
of hydronium ions,
we can simply plug in that concentration
into the equation for a pH.
So the pH is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of 3.6
times 10 to the negative fourth
which is 3.44.
Notice that we have
two significant figures
for the concentration
therefore we have two decimal
places in our final answer.
So plugging in negative
log of 3.6 times 10
to the negative fourth on your calculator,
it gives you 3.44 for the answer.
However, there's a way
of estimating the pH
without using a calculator.
The first step is to say 3.6
times 10 to the negative fourth
is between one times 10
to the negative fourth
and 10 times 10 to the negative fourth.
10 times 10 to the negative fourth
is the same thing as one times
10 to the negative third.
If the concentration of hydronium ions
is one times 10 to the negative third,
you can find the pH of that
without using a calculator
if you know your logarithms.
The pH would be equal to three.
And if the concentration of hydronium ions
is one times 10 to the negative fourth,
this is a log base 10 system,
so the negative log of one
times 10 to the negative fourth
would be equal to a pH of four.
Since 3.6 times 10 to the negative fourth
is between one times 10
to the negative fourth
and one times 10 to the negative third,
the pH of this concentration
must be between a pH of four
and a pH three.
And we saw that with our calculator.
The pH came out to be 3.44.
Let's say we have some cleaning
solution at room temperature
which is 25 degrees Celsius
and the cleaning solution
has some ammonia in it.
The concentration of hydroxide
ions in solution is measured
to be 2.0 times 10 to
the negative third molar.
And our goal is to calculate
the pH of the solution.
The first step is to use the Kw equation
which says that the
concentration of hydronium ions
times the concentration of
hydroxide ions is equal to Kw
which at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to 1.0 times
10 to the negative 14th.
We can go ahead and plug
in the concentration
of hydroxide ions into the Kw equation.
So that's 2.0 times 10
to the negative third.
And we don't know the
concentration of hydronium ions is,
we'll make that X and so
we're gonna solve for X.
And this is equal to one
times 10 to the negative 14th.
Solving for X, X is equal to 5.0
times 10 to the negative 12
and this is the equal to the concentration
of hydronium ions.
So the concentration of
hydronium ions is equal to 5.0
times 10 to the negative 12 molar.
Now that we know the
concentration of hydronium ions
in solution, we can plug that
into our equation for pH.
So the pH is equal to
the negative log of 5.0
times 10 to the negative
12 which gives a 11.30.
Notice since we have
two significant figures
for the concentration,
we need two decimal places
for our final answer.
Now that we've calculated the pH
of three different substances,
let's find where they rank on
what's called the pH scale.
The pH scale normally
goes from zero to 14.
However, it is possible to go
below zero or to go above 14.
We calculate that a sample of pure water
at 25 degrees Celsius has a pH of 7.00.
That puts it right in the
middle of the pH scale.
And we say that water
is a neutral substance.
An aqueous solution has a pH of seven
is considered to be a neutral solution.
An aqueous solution with
a pH less than seven
is considered to be an acidic solution.
So for lemon juice, we
calculated the pH to be 3.44
which is right about here on our pH scale
so lemon juice is acidic.
And as you go to the left on the pH scale,
you increase in acidity.
For example, if we had a
solution with a pH of six
and another solution with a pH of five,
the solution with a pH
of five is more acidic.
And going back to our equation for pH,
pH is equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions.
This is log based 10.
Therefore the solution with the pH of five
is 10 times more acidic than
a solution with a pH of six.
And because of the way
the equation written,
the higher the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution,
the lower the value for the pH.
And the lower the concentration
for the hydronium ions
in solution, the higher
the value for them pH.
And if an aqueous solution
has a pH greater than seven,
we say that aqueous solution is basic.
For example, our cleaning
solution with some ammonia in it
had a pH of 11.30
so that's right about
here on the pH scale.
So we would consider that
cleaning solution with ammonia
to be a basic solution.
As you move to the right on the pH scale,
you increase in the
basicity of the solution.
So we've seen that pH is
equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions
which you could also write pH is equal
to the negative log of H+.
Running it this way on the
right makes it easier to see
how the pattern works
for other situations.
For example, pOH is
defined as the negative log
of the concentration of hydroxide ions.
So we have the pOH here
and then we have the
concentration of hydroxide ions
over here, the same way we wrote pH
with the concentration
of H+ ions over here.
And also pKw would be equal
to the negative log of Kw.
Let's go back to the Kw equation
which says that the
concentration of hydronium ions
times the concentration of hydroxide ions
is equal to Kw.
If we take the negative log
of both sides of this equation
and we use our log properties,
we get that the negative
log of the concentration
of H3O+ plus the negative
of OH- is equal to the negative log of Kw.
The negative log of the
concentration of H3O+
is just equal to the pH,
so we can write the pH down here,
plus the negative log of the concentration
of hydroxide ions,
that's equal to the pOH.
So we have pH plus pOH is
equal to the negative log of Kw
is equal to pKw.
At 25 degrees Celsius, Kw is equal to 1.0
times 10 to the negative 14.
Therefore the negative log of
Kw is the negative log of 1.0
times 10 to the negative
14 which is equal to 14.00.
So we can plug in 14.00 in for pKw
which gives us a very useful equation
that says that the pH plus
the pOH is equal to 14.00.
And this equation is true
when the temperature
is 25 degrees Celsius.